*cue mystery music*
*clap clap*
Meme review.
The lore so far. What we have gathered so far:
Johnny -- he's a compulsive liar. He wants sugar but most importantly,
he's a hero. He puts up with online abuse, domestic abuse, and he's only two years old.
That's crazy! Moving on in the family, we have
Refrigerator, now we don't know a lot about refrigerator.
We don't know how he became part of the family, but he's what lifts Johnny's up.
He's one makes Johnny pull through all the abuse.
We also have Chiya a very important character try not to stare at Chiya for too long.
He or she will consume your soul, you have been advised. (Jesus Chiya)
But perhaps most important of all the leader, the mastermind behind it all.
Yes, I'm talking about papa.
That's right. We don't say daddy anymore.
We say yes Papa. If you see daddy you best be running.
Especially if you're carrying sugar or any sweet items or perhaps toothpaste. Run, run like the wind.
Because Papa's gonna get you.
Now. What are you talking about? Oh, I'm talking about this video. By BillionSurpriseToys
Which apparently has,
134 million views!!!!
Okay. *Pewds weird laugh*
It's pretty decent. I suppose if you haven't watched the video. Don't worry. I will sing it for you.It goes: Papa: Johnny Johnny.
Johnny: Yes papa. Yes Papa. Papa: Eating sugar?
Eating sugar?
Johnny: Nooo papa. *Pewds laughs*
Papa: Telling lies?
Telling lies? Johnny: No papa! Papa: OPEN WIDE.
OPEN WIDE.
HAHAHAHA
134 million views everybody.
What does it take to become big on YouTube? Just make this. Just create this. Now,
we're trying to understand why this video got so popular.
Why does Papa want Johnny so badly? We don't know. We're still figuring out all the details. *Pewds reads* Johnny Johnny.
Yes, Papa. Eating sugar? No papa! Telling lies? No papa! Open wide. Damn. Damn (jimin);)
That's an open wide mouth. (R.I.P Jimin)
Incredible, so we have refrigerator.
Stores things inside of him.
Why is he sentient? He's not a fan :/
Mommy. Don't care Johnny: - self innocent,
manipulative,
omnipotent. I don't trust him either, okay
Chiya...
I don't care.
We have ice cream. Who apparently sleeps with Johnny.
There's so much lore involved in this family.
there's so many different dots that are connected, but they all
[?] lead back to Papa.
The entire family could starve to death at any moment because Papa isn't letting them eEAEEAU.
Apparently,
Johnny is confirmed for smash.
That's epic.
But there's something about Johnny as well that makes me a bit uncomfortable.
I don't like him. I'm gonna be honest. I don't like him.
Johnny Johnny. Oh hi Mark
Hitting Lisa? Hitting Lisa?
I did naht.
Telling lies?
Bullshit Mark
Open mouth. Open mouth.
Ha ha ha.
Johnny Johnny.
Yes papa.
It's been 10 years already you have to let me go.
NO PAPA.
The crash wasn't your fault, Johnny.
*Pweds screeching noise*
This nursery rhyme is also very good.
We have the Johnnyyyy.
Doo doo doo doo doo do do do.
Yes Papa. Yes Papa.
No. Okay. Let it be known if there's one thing
you know about this meme, I did not chill this meme I have nothing to do with this meme getting
popular and I'm here to kill it all. I've discovered this meme dark secret.
Everyone is perplexed why this meme is popular, who made this meme, there's a ton of mystery.
I will reveal it. But first of all, I must review it.
To kill it.
I'm here to save the universe god damn it. (FINALLY)
First of all.
I mean second of all. Are we just gonna sit here and pretend like toys in Japan...
never existed?
Everyone is looking at the Johnny Johnny nursery rhymes going:
"oH ItS So weird.I dOn'T UnDErSTAnd thIS?"
HAVE YOU NOT watched toys in Japan, okay??!
Are we all of a sudden pretending that this never got a 60 million views?
Okay
so don't [nag] me about Johnny Johnny being weird,
with tHIS,
Is what kids watch.
The Vox, of course, Vox dot com, of COURSE
Another enemy made a meme review,
of this meme.
MmmmHmm
Suspicious..
Yes, I know. But the message they they point out is that in the essence?
It seems to be a rare meme that appeals to every kind of meme maker and every kind of audience.
NOT ME. *echo effect*
Vox, I hate this meme you have no taste!! You have no integrity if you shkill this meme
Peh. Peh.
Okay, and number three.
Okay, this meme is getting DMCA takedown left and right. Whoever is creating these videos,
is deleting anyone that is trying to meme it,
whether it's some Twitter, Dailymotion, or YouTube >:o
- if you upload with Johnny Johnny, your video will get deleted
So the tweet announcing my last video, was taken down by the guys who made the Johnny Johnny video.
The following material has been removed new video Johnny Johnny Yes papa.
Cyranek's video got removed.
Great.
Hey remember when there was a meme that we have to vote for the EU to not
copyright law around memes so that you couldn't just delete memes? Oh, that's right,
we are already living it. Laws don't matter because YouTube and Twitter. They don't care
Oh someone sent a DMCA?
Well, we better remove the video.
I even debated whether I should not review this meme because I know it will just get a DMCA takedown.
And the thing is,
the most annoying thing about this whole thing is,
it's not even original content.
You're making a nursery rhyme.
You don't own the nursery rhyme. It is a public domain, but YouTube is like oh, okay. Sorry papa. Sorry papa
Yeah. Yeah. Go ahead and DMCA this video
Sumimasen. Gomenasai. Papa.
What the real enemy of this meme is...
Is Indians, okay.
This video is clearly made by Indians.
Now. This is not racism. Let it be clear.
This is another evidence of the Indians taking over YouTube. (Like T-Series :O)
First off,
We had T-Series. They're taking over my channel in subscriber count. Everyone's like well, I never heard of T-Series.
Oh, you haven't? Haven't you? That's right.
The Indians are sneaking in on us, and now they're doing it again with this channel,
being created obviously by Indians and they're attacking us through our memes.
First, they take our memes.
And they take our freedom,
and I'm not just gonna sit here irresponsibly, like Vox News
pretending like everyone loves this meme when it's clearly killing not just me, but the Internet as well along with it.
We need to kill papa.
Papa needs to die. That's why I'm giving this meme.
*clap clap*
A Zero.
Bye papa. Bye papa >:-O
NEXT. MEME. *mating call off a duck*
There's a thing that annoys me even more about this super meme is that everyone has been so preoccupied with the Yes Papa meme
they've been brainwashed,
and they wasn't been posting any other decent memes.
We have the,
Let me guess, your home. It was and it was beautiful.
It's just sad man. This is sad
Let me guess your home. It was and it was beautiful. Hey, what's next.
Minecraft, perhaps?
Let me guess, your home?  It was. And it was beautiful.
Another marvel meme. How long has it been?
They just keep coming. They just keep coming. No, to be fair, Largetrap did a green-screen on it.
So if you want to meme this,
The floodgates are open. Enjoy everyone
You brought you face to face with the master of the mystic arts, where do you think he brought you
Let me guess... your home?
It was.
It was beautiful.
Eyy, it's Minecraft everybody. Who would've thought?
Hmm. My favorite one is the one largetrap did.
Let me guess, your home?
Like you spend all this time
Greenscreening out this and you can put anything. So what do you put?
Peter Griffin. That- I would love to live inside that man.
*clap clap*
I'm giving this meme a three.
Okay.
Just because I'm desperate to get any other meme out there at this point.
Last but not least, Ben Shapiro.
The destroyer of worlds, epic style. (Well, Daniel, I can really only think of one way to answer this and it's in musical form, )
So I think we're gonna have to do that.
*music starts playing*
Okay
Okay, okay, okay, oKAY.
You may or may not have seen these videos pop up in your recommended feed going: Ben Shapiro DESTROYS
every college snowflake,
delusional leftist CONFRONTS ben Shapiro
Ben Shapiro CRUSHES,
Ben Shapiro ANNIHILATES,
Ben Shapiro DESTROYS.
My favorite video of Ben Shapiro,
these are all great by the way
is Ben Shapiro
DESTROYS,
my sand castle that I spent all day making. You just got trolled lig tard. You can't build sand castles.
They're not real your dumb ball. Ben Shapiro,
DEMOLISHES woman in line at Walgreens for saying Tuesday is basically Monday too.
Women, am I right? Brofist the screen right now if you agree. Ben Shapiro
REACHES such heights of LOGIC he
INSTANTLY ACHIEVES APOTHEOSIS
*mumbles random words and laughs*
Okay, I can't even say it. I don't even want to say it ironically. The meme is  just so du-, okay it's epic
Is this video going to be ten minutes? I don't know? I still see bananas in my room.
Can't take back the love that I gave you. It's to the point where I love and I hate you, okay?
So basically, I am Monky. It's this video ten minutes
This were really bad memes this week sumimase and everybody like for Eminem ignore for Logan Paul
That's it for now. I see you guys next time.
*clap clap*